TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello.
I'm Timothy Jordan,
and this is your update
about the coolest developer news
from Google in the last week.
Android KTX is a set
of extensions designed
to make writing Kotlin code
for Android more concise,
idiomatic, and pleasant.
It provides an API layer on
top of both Android framework
and support library, and the
preview is now available.
Head on over to the post,
linked in the description
below, for a video, code, and
a link to the GitHub repo.
The new server timing
API in Chrome 65 Beta
allows web servers to pass
performance timing information
via HTTP headers to browsers.
This new API provides you with
a more complete performance
picture that includes
the speed of both
the client and the server.
Other features in this release
are listed on the post.
Beginning in July 2018, with
the release of Chrome 68,
Chrome will mark all
HTTP sites as not secure.
HTTPS is easier and
cheaper than ever before,
and it unlocks both
performance improvements
and powerful new features that
are too sensitive for HTTP.
Head on over to the
post for a set-up guide
that will help you get started.
Cloud TPUs are now available in
beta on Google Cloud Platform
to help machine learning
experts train and run their ML
models more quickly.
TPU stands for Tensor
Processing Unit,
and each Cloud TPU board
contains four custom chips
that Google has designed
in-house, specifically
for machine learning.
You'll need to request
quota to get started.
More details and the sign-up
form are on the post.
GPUs in Kubernetes
Engine are now
in beta and ready to be
used widely, from the latest
Kubernetes Engine release.
Using GPUs in Kubernetes
Engine can turbocharge
compute-intensive applications
like machine learning, image
processing, and
financial modeling.
Universal App
Campaigns make it easy
for you to reach users and grow
your app business at scale,
and we recently launched a
new interactive education
program for them.
For more details and
a link to the course,
head on over to the post,
linked in the description below.
Please like,
subscribe, and share.
I'm Timothy Jordan, and
I'll see you next week.
Thanks for watching another
episode of The Developer Show.
To catch some of our
prior week's episodes,
they're right over here.
[MUSIC PLAYING]